Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
October 23rd,
2017 what's going on?
How is,
yeah.
Um,
I am in Atlanta.
I am back in Atlanta to continue on my acting Gig on a rainy day here.
Oh,
rainy days and Mondays.
Oh kid be down.
Who the fuck would write a song like that?
You know,
it's like,
isn't a world depressed enough?
Rainy days and Mondays always get you down or how do you feel on Tuesday when
it's partly cloudy?
You're miserable.
Cont you play in music.
Isn't your job supposed to be the cheer people up?
I should talk him at one time beck put out an album and I guess it was supposed
to be like some thing when he was going through a depression and then he had a
happier album and uh,
I bought them one where he was more depressed and I remember my wife was like,
well,
why would you buy that one?
I don't know,
cause I can relate.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
so I'm back here,
uh,
in Atlanta.
Just landed in this fucking rain and all of this shit.
And uh,
you know,
we were up there in the holding pattern and all that.
It's going to be a little 25 minutes,
all that stuff.
People all huffing and puffing and all I'm thinking is,
yeah,
dude,
take another 55 minutes.
Just don't fucking crash.
I don't care how long this takes.
Right.
So I get back to the hotel,
everything goes great.
Some of this guy fucking lands it.
Um,
I don't know how they do it.
It's fucking amazing that they're not freaking out or is it just like,
I couldn't see anything out my window.
Um,
and uh,
I get back to the hotel room has got a fuck,
I got to do the podcast,
let me order a little bit of room service.
So I call up,
you know,
get a little grilled cheese sandwich,
little Turkey BLT.
What do you got?
What you got on your lunchtime menu?
When I called the Guy Up,
right?
And he's like,
hello rum service.
And I said,
yeah,
I'd like to order some food to the Roman.
He goes,
Oh,
I'm sorry we don't have any rooms.
City.
Like I forget who said it,
but he wouldn't like this happy tone.
Oh,
you know,
unfortunately we can't do that right now.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
That's what you said.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
We can't do that right now.
Oh yeah,
you don't sound sorry.
You sound kind of chipper.
Why don't you have an,
why don't you have the proper tone in your voice?
Could you at least pretend to sound a quarter as disappointed as I am right now
that I have to do my fucking podcast on an empty stomach.
This podcast is going to suck right now,
cause all I'm going to be thinking about is a grilled cheese sandwich that I'm
not eating.
All the sun just came out.
Here comes this dude.
The dude.
Do you know it's fucked up.
George Harrison wrote dad and he's dead.
I bet the rainy days in summer Mondays Guy,
he's still alive.
You know why?
Because God doesn't want to hang out with them.
It was just the George Harrison.
Here comes this guy.
Sounds all right.
I did a good job on this one.
Huh?
Must not have been sleepy and nodding off.
Like when I made the rainy days and Mondays content,
uh,
Jesus IOP kill somebody,
so I have a reason to send them down.
Well wait,
I'm God.
I can send them down there anyways.
You know what,
fucking cello.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead.
Uh,
back in Atlanta.
Going to knock out a couple more days on this.
Uh,
what I'm telling you,
man,
it's really looking like a great one film that I'm working on.
And uh,
then I go back to go see my wife and my dawn is that my daughter went there,
get to go back,
hang out with them before,
uh,
the fuck am I doing this weekend.
Oh my God,
we're doing it.
I'm doing the first ever all things.
Comedy podcast,
network,
podcast festival
in Phoenix,
Arizona.
Do they say podcast enough in that?
Um,
by the way,
I'm supposed to mention that bud light will be the official beer of the all
things comedy festival.
All right?
We got a little booze in there for Billy booze lists.
67 days,
a 67 days,
no boost.
When we taste,
I'm just,
because I'm not drinking doesn't mean you can't come to the all things,
comedy festival and Phoenix,
Arizona,
this,
uh,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and listened to some of the best podcasts and then in the world and the
universe.
I'm going to go Donald Trump here while enjoying an ice cold bud light.
They go,
hey,
like that little fucking commercial there.
Um,
I'll be doing my podcasts for the first.
I don't know how I'm going to do it cause I'm going to do it just like I do
this.
So I just fucking lay down on a couch or a bed.
I feel at some point I do have to address the crowd.
I think the fact that I have no idea what the fuck is going to happen.
Like I don't know what I'm supposed to do.
The crowd doesn't know what they're supposed to do.
I think,
uh,
something good's going to happen that that is my,
that is my prediction or something bad.
Well,
maybe it sucks,
but you know,
what is the Internet?
The Internet like better than something that's amazing.
Something that sucks.
So no matter what I feel like it's going to be a win.
Um,
anyway,
67 fucking God damn days,
no booze.
I feel great.
You know,
I look better.
I've lost weight,
you know,
my livers happy,
sure.
All of those things.
But I gotta tell you something.
I really miss it.
I definitely miss it.
You know,
I had such a fucking amazing weekend played,
uh,
Austin City live.
The best sounding venue I've ever fucking been in.
The sound was,
was incredible.
They shoot Austin city limits there.
The sound was fucking incredible.
I worked with Dean del Ray.
He murdered all weekend.
Um,
I recorded when I was there.
They were such pros.
They handed it to me.
They had all three sets.
Are All of them already mixed?
And also in what you guys said something about pro tools,
like I could just hook it up into pro tools and switch the mixing adjust stuff
if I wanted to.
Um,
it was the most professional,
best sounding,
coolest fucking venue that I've played in the,
in the states.
I think it was unreal.
And they had all these fucking photos from back in the day,
all the way back to the first,
uh,
Willie Nelson was the first guest that they had in 1974,
I believe this is their third venue,
but of course they had the Stevie Ray Vaughan one,
um,
the ill young,
just,
just everybody,
everybody played there.
And uh,
so that was incredible.
So anyways,
and then there was this place,
Lambert's barbecue right around the corner,
which might've been the best barbecue I ever got.
Just not only the taste,
the quality of the meat.
I went there the first time and I got the pulled pork was fucking incredible.
I got to give these guys a shout out.
And then,
um,
I went back there again yesterday and one of the,
uh,
people that worked at the,
Austin City live goes,
I used to work there,
get the Ribeye.
And I got it.
It was,
it was,
I forget what they,
they,
I don't know,
put it in coffee and something else was the rub and it was fucking outstanding.
Um,
incredible food and all that shit.
So anyways,
so I went out there,
I scheduled this weekend out there around the Formula One race.
Right?
That's all I was going to do.
I was going to go there,
play Austin City live and then go to the f one race and then that was it.
That was going to be my fucking make a wish weekend was going to be perfect.
However I get there and somebody tells me,
hey,
you know Jimmy Vaughan is playing um,
the fuck,
what's the name of the venue?
We just went there,
something sky something,
sky venue or something.
This little bar,
cool ass fucking bar was like,
Jimmy Vaughan is going to be playing down there.
Uh,
I only had one show Saturday night.
You guys should go down and check them out.
Went down and checked them out.
Sat in a booth like five feet away from the stage.
So the Great Jimmy Vaughn had this unbelievable fucking keyboard player and
drummer and I just got to watch them play a set.
It was this big CD album release party that they were having a,
we got to meet him in between sets.
Could not have been nice,
nicer,
more generous,
which is really warm.
Great Guy.
And um,
I got to tell you,
man,
this,
there was this one ass hole in the crowd.
The more I go to like music shows like that,
they always talk about how comedians get heckled.
Like we get heckled,
you know,
cause most of the times we deserve it.
We say something that isn't funny.
Are we annoy somebody,
right.
This guy's up there.
He's,
he's playing music and he's killing it and it sounds great.
This asshole in the crowd
said some,
I don't want to fucking hear that shit.
I want to loan like five feet away yelling at him like he hired him for his
private birthday party.
And uh,
I don't know how,
I don't know how Jimmy kept his composure.
I don't know how we did.
Like,
I,
I couldn't believe it didn't smash the fucking guitar over his head.
He just was like,
Nah man,
you know,
I'm up here and playing music.
This fucking loser who's never done shit with his life as far as I can tell.
He's with some woman who literally falling down drunk,
fell down drunk and he got her another fucking beer and these,
you know,
other than that,
it was like this perfect evening and I just was as a performer was astounded the
classy way that he handled that guy.
Cause uh,
God knows I wouldn't have,
but um,
other than that asshole,
it was just this incredible night and me and dean would just sit in there like,
you know,
a couple of kids could not believe that.
We got to see him and it got to see him play.
Like it was just classic old school musician,
you know,
we were out in the,
in the fucking parking lot and he just pulls up,
drove himself to the Gig,
you know,
just old school shit goes in,
walks up on stage,
looked fucking great plugs in,
tunes up people.
He acts tuning up his own guitar,
you know,
all of that shit.
People,
ed,
Jim and he just started looking non whatever.
He's all tuned up,
walks off stage,
comes back 10 minutes later and just proceeds to absolutely murdered for like 90
minutes.
Right.
So like that wasn't great enough.
I would go,
dude,
you believe we're going to be seeing this guy and we're going to go to this race
the next day.
So anyways,
we're with some of the people from Austin City live.
Then I go,
by the way,
I go,
who's playing your,
your venue?
Uh,
who comes in their necks and they go,
Primus,
I got when they go Sunday night,
I go get the fuck outta here.
I've never seen them.
All right.
Tim Alexander is one of my favorite fucking drummers of all time.
I got to see this guy live.
So I changed my fucking flight and they go,
hi ma'am,
we'll fucking hook you up.
And um,
yeah,
we go to the race.
I know this is probably annoying to a lot of you guys thought I've got to do all
of this shit,
but I,
I have to tell you what am I going to lie and act like I didn't have a great
week.
My source to tone down my joy because you're in a goddamned cubicle right now.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that I fucking humiliated myself for eight,
the first eight years of my standup career before I finally figured out how to
be funny it a,
that I'm a 25 year a overnight success.
Can I continue without pissing off too many of you?
I know.
How the fucking,
uh,
I know the Internet is,
I know how it works.
We'll fuck you all right.
Just all this.
If I ever get sick,
I don't need to have a fucking make a wish because I already,
I lived at this weekend,
so we go to the God damn race.
Um,
and uh,
we sit,
we were sitting in turn 12 which was the fucking place to be.
You know,
the first race I went to up in Montreal,
I was on the start finish line and it was great to watch him go flying by and
170,
80 miles an hour,
but you could barely see them.
You want to be in the turns where they got,
they got to stomp on the breaks and that's where the race and happens.
That's where the passing happens.
Do we were there,
we saw a fucking,
uh,
Lewis Hamilton Past Matt Maxavenue staff and the two best drivers in the world
on the two best teams.
You know,
Mercedes in a Ferrari right in front of us.
And on that same fucking turn I think,
uh,
but both tests pass somebody.
We got to see Hamilton past somebody else after he had pitted and he had to try
to get back into first place again.
We saw him pass again.
And then on the final lap we saw Max Verstappen go around Kimmy Raikkonen
readiness.
They would disappear.
And around the fucking was at 12,
13,
14,
15 and [inaudible] 16 we could see 12,
13,
14 and 16 turns.
And then up the hill you can see a turn one.
And then over to the left you could see like turn,
I don't know what it was,
five or six was ridiculous.
Um,
if you ever go there,
you've got to sit and turn 12th.
I'm telling you,
or somewhere around there,
you get to see all of,
like,
just get a map of,
of the,
uh,
of the track.
And from here on out,
I don't give a fuck what race I go to.
I'm going to look and see which,
which turn has the sharpest fucking turned,
uh,
after a straight away or whatever.
And that's where I'm sitting because we actually saw a little bit of an
accident,
I believe one of the,
uh,
the American teams,
the Haas car got spun out.
That was right in front of us.
And,
uh,
through Dean Delray was flipping the fuck out like three times during the race.
During those passes,
he fucking held up his forearm and he had goosebumps watching these guys
slamming on the brakes going around each other.
You know,
he's a motorcycle fucking car freak.
He was losing his shit.
Um,
and he was,
he was so going nuts.
I was like laughing half of the time,
you know,
when you bring somebody to something you and you want to,
you want them to have a good time.
You're so afraid that they're going to look at you like you're into this shit,
dude,
I'm bored.
You know,
they're gonna need more fucking cheese and crackers for me to eat.
He was losing his mind freaking out.
So anyways,
as if the race wasn't good enough,
Max Verstappen is right on Kimmy Raycon's ass through 12,
13,
14,
15 the whole time and everybody is on their feet going fucking crazy.
And then at the last second is there going like up the hill.
He got around him and everybody was going nuts.
And um,
he ends up coming in third place.
He's on the podium.
Everything is great.
Uh,
we get out of there.
Um,
oh,
I've forgotten the beginning of the race.
Uh,
when they did the whole,
uh,
Michael buffer did all the announcements,
which some,
some,
you know,
some race and fans didn't like,
cause they're all fucking snobby and shit.
I saw a couple of American fans apologize and if fuck you,
this is America.
All right,
we overeat and we're loud.
All right.
If you don't like it,
don't have a fucking race here.
You asshole
Jesus Christ.
Do you get all upset when the fucking Italians cry every time a Ferrari's and
first place for a lap
fucking stuck up cunt anyways.
And they actually,
when they brought out Daniel Ricardo,
they actually,
uh,
oh fuck is this on right now?
All right,
sorry.
Little technical technical difficulty there.
When they brought him out,
uh,
we'll,
Buxton had wrote,
written all the,
uh,
the intros and when they brought out Danny Ricardo,
they fucking the dad Michael Buffer,
say Ricky rocket.
Remember when I couldn't remember the guys names and I was saying Rick,
uh,
Ricky Rican Berg and all of that shit.
Cause I,
you know,
so new to the sport.
And one time I called Daniel Ricardo Rikki rocket,
obviously knowing that that was the drummer from poison.
So,
uh,
he actually said that
fucking nuts is that.
So anyways,
at some point I got to get a picture with Ricky rocket and Daniel Ricardo.
See if that ever fucking happen.
Who knows,
who knows?
Maybe Rikki rocket cares this shout out.
Next thing you know,
he gets into the race,
he goes to fucking Austin.
He's also sitting in turned 12.
But Daniel,
Ricardo,
bi,
you know what,
it's,
it'd be Drazen at that point.
It's never going to fucking happen.
Whatever.
So anyways,
this morning I wake up and I'm looking at the final,
you know,
results and everything to see who won what.
And I noticed that all of a sudden Max Verstappen is down in fourth place and,
uh,
there's all this whole fucking,
days of thunder,
Ricky Bobby fucking controversy.
I guess he fucking went off on this.
I guess this is racing steward who fucked him over in Japan,
Mexico and now in Austin.
And he was so mad.
He said he hoped that the fans don't show up in Austin next year.
It's this like,
dude,
he's kind of fucking year around the globe.
There's no reason to single us out.
Right.
Did you not like your nickname and the fucking intros?
Sorry.
Um,
but anyways,
it was off.
It was a phenomenal race.
I'm actually blowing through so much of this shit.
I should probably try and slow down here,
but I have to get to the next thing.
So then we left there and then we went.
I,
my,
my wife,
better night,
listen to this podcast,
she's going to get annoyed with me.
Then we went back to the hotel,
dropped off our shit,
and uh,
we went back down over to the venue and we got to see,
uh,
we got to see Primus and they basically opened for themselves,
played like for an hour and then took a half hour break and played it for
another 90 minutes.
And um,
I gotta be honest with you,
I am not a drug,
but I actually,
with all the video shit that they had going on in the host psychedelic vibe,
oh,
by the way,
another heckler at that show,
like Larry's one of his pedals,
if something wasn't working,
you know,
so less is talking to the crowd talking about,
he's actually talking about that.
What does that blue,
you know those damn blue color tweak?
Ours isn't that rock.
That's how old town.
Yeah,
that's fucking song.
He was talking about how he came up with that tweakers I thought he was talking
about Meth,
you know,
I didn't know it was about the water's being stolen from northern California.
So he's sitting there talking about it because they're trying to fix Larry's
pedals and this guy in the crowd goes,
stop fucking preaching.
Can you,
I,
I was beside myself.
I would think everybody in the crowd would just beat the shit out of me,
but less once again to both of them just handled it like a pro.
He joked is way out of it.
He said something fucking hilarious about,
uh,
you know,
presenting any questions that you had,
please present them in written form.
A true or false questions worked best for me.
I'm butchering it,
but it was like really funny to the point.
I was actually kind of happy the guy heckled them cause you know,
les is fucking hilarious.
So,
um,
I finally got to see Tim Alexander play live.
His fucking kit is,
it's fucking,
eh,
he has like a double bass pedal on it,
like a 20 inch bass drum.
Um,
and they had all of this stuff going on in the background and I'm sitting there,
you know,
trying to figure out,
uh,
you know,
what Tim is playing and all of that shit.
And,
uh,
after they open for themselves,
they took a half hour break.
Then they came out and they started playing all this stuff off to their new
album.
I hope I say this right.
Desaturating seven.
Um,
and they had all this video stuff going on and actually looked over a dean at
one point,
I believe when they had elephants jumping on trampolines.
And
in the way that the filter was on it,
it looked like,
was that really cool movie Vin vin diesel did where he couldn't see just how you
would look?
I keep thinking Riddick Bowe I know it's not that that was a boxer.
I forget what the,
I can never remember the name of the movie,
but it was like sorta in that sort of filter and it was an elephant jumping up
and down on a trampoline and then it became three.
And then one of them started doing somersaults.
And what I've loved when it came down,
like the trunk would like,
uh,
we'd be like fluttering in the wind is it came down and I literally looked over
at dean.
I go,
you know what?
I've never had to stop before,
but I really wish I was on drugs right now.
I'm not a drug guy.
You know,
our,
I've stayed away from,
you know,
I smoke weed every once in a while,
usually when I'm not drinking because I'm so fucking bored.
I don't know how straight edge people do it.
I really don't.
Um,
but I pretty much stayed away from all of like the evil drugs other than
alcohol.
I think alcohol is an evil drug.
It's an angry drunk,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like weed is cool,
mushrooms are cool,
but like coke is evil,
alcohols evil.
Um,
I dunno.
I feel like the shit that just makes you kind of sit around,
you can't really do anything.
Just giggling it yourself,
you know?
I don't know why anybody would like,
just choose
to,
uh,
stay in the dark side.
I don't know.
Maybe you just a fucking dark human being in your relate to it,
but you'd think he'd want to go the opposite way.
I don't fucking know.
But,
um,
I've never taken mushrooms or anything like that,
but,
um,
I dunno,
that was the first time I was just like,
you know,
I wouldn't mind,
I wouldn't have minded being in like an altered state throughout this if I could
have just given myself.
I just always worry that I would,
I would freak out.
That's why I never,
you know,
like my generation always,
they were always like,
uh,
you know,
they had the old thing telling you stories about people took LSD and they pulled
their eyeballs out and fucking jump.
I mean,
I would never fuck with LSD either,
but like,
uh,
I dunno
was actually going like,
you know,
I think,
uh,
this would have been one of those times.
I mean,
if I just did mushrooms once every 49 years,
it's like,
be like Haley's comet,
you know,
sorta.
I don't fucking though.
All I know was they were unbelievable.
And,
uh,
I can't even,
I don't even know,
which was my favorite.
I think it was,
uh,
southbound,
packet Durham is probably my favorite.
It was just an unbelievable fell off.
The whole night was just fucking incredible.
And that was my weekend.
I got to do three shows at Austin City live the best venue as far as sound I've
ever performed in,
I think.
Got to see Jimmy Vaughan in this small little bar.
Yeah,
like doing the world a favor.
He doesn't need to do that kid comes down,
right?
And then I got this [inaudible] f one race and then I saw primus after that,
and then I come back to Atlanta to do a fucking movie to pretend to be somebody
else.
I swear to God there's a piano waiting to fall on my fucking head.
At some point during this week,
something's going to happen and actually you already did.
What am I going to talk to you about it with some other fucking bullshit,
getting some work done in the house in the workers came there and somebody said,
hey,
the door to your house was open.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
Did somebody break into our house?
So I'm dealing with that.
But you know what?
That's what happens.
That is what happens when you have all this good stuff going on.
Something,
something happens,
you stubbed your fucking toe side,
you get audited,
something's going to happen.
I don't fucking know.
So anyways,
uh,
doing all of this shit,
I missed pretty much all of,
uh,
the football and all of that crap.
Uh,
for this weekend.
I do know that the Patriots beat the Falcons.
Um,
so that's cool for and to do,
we actually have a strong division.
Bill's a foreign to patriots of foreign to dolphins are foreign to jets or a
what are they?
The three and a what would that be?
He played six games.
Three and three.
I Dunno,
I don't know what they are.
Um,
are there might be three and five cause I think we might've had a bye week.
I don't know what,
but uh,
the AFC east after all these years of being so fucking weak is actually a really
competitive division.
That shit.
So that's pretty exciting.
And um,
I watched,
uh,
what did I watch?
My apologies,
by the way,
my apologies to the fucking Houston Astros.
I love your uniforms.
I just have a watch baseball and so long I thought they still had those shitty
once that Jeff Bagwell had to where you fucking uniforms are great.
And I got to give a shout out to sports illustrated.
Some guy,
I was watching this pregame cause I watched game six and seven,
you know,
when I was uh,
waiting to go on and I thought I was convinced cc Sabathia game seven.
I thought the Yankees,
we're going to have that one.
Um,
but anyways,
they were talking about before like game seven,
that some guy,
I don't know who wrote it in sports illustrated in 2014 the year they Astros'
win 70 and 92 he put them on the cover of sports illustrated and said,
uh,
you know,
please welcome your 2017 world series champions.
He said that in 2014 when he was 70 and 92 are in the midst of being that he or
she said that,
right.
And then they come back from the story and the gay host and the sports program
go there.
That was a pretty good prediction.
It's like pretty good.
That's fucking unbelievable.
Look,
anybody right now can look at the Yankees and go like,
Hey,
yeah,
I think they're going to win it next year.
Then when it the year after or sometime within the next three years,
that is not a big prediction.
All right.
They got all this young talent that they're fucking playing great.
They way over achieved as far as what the organization thought they were going
to do this year.
They came one game away from the world series.
Anybody can say that these guys are going to win another one.
You know,
that's what I think.
I think they're gonna win another one here in the next few years.
But to fucking look at the Astros who've never fucking won in 2014 and then pick
the year,
I think at the next three years,
blah blah blah.
That would have been great.
But to actually nail the year,
I mean they haven't won yet,
but [inaudible] was a pretty good prediction.
I don't know if that,
the guy was a little jealous.
My nuts.
I'm trying not to talk all sports cause I know people are fucking get nuts with
that sometimes.
So let me fucking go.
Uh,
first of all,
why I'm,
I'm really cursing a lot.
I don't know why.
Probably because I was on a plane today and we suck when after I want,
I've been on a plane,
but,
uh,
let's get back to drugs and booze.
All right.
Um,
this is what I realized.
I like,
I like getting fucked up.
I do.
I really enjoy it.
I like getting hammered or fucking,
you know,
every once in a mile smoking some weed.
I do.
And I'm not an addictive personality
as a cop show up to see what's under my bed right now.
Um,
I hope you guys could hear the siren in the background.
I hope you didn't think I was alluding to the fact that I killed a hooker or
something was I was talking about drugs.
A Simon went by.
Sometimes this fucking thing doesn't pick it up.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
so like now I have a drank or done anything for like 67 days and I could go for
the rest of my life.
I could do it,
but it's just,
it's so,
it's like really a,
I don't know.
It's boring.
I don't know how,
like I have to commend everybody
who chuck,
who gets into a program and just fucking does that.
I don't know how you do it,
but it's,
it's,
it's amazing.
And I feel like in a way by me saying how fucking boring it is.
I'm actually fucking with your sobriety,
so I apologize.
But,
um,
do you guys been watching Bert Kreischer by the way?
Going sober for October and I believe Tom Segora,
they always do like those battles,
like losing weight and being sober and all that shit.
And I think Joe Rogan is doing it too.
Um,
so all I know about from the,
what I know about the three of them November better getting the fetal position
because I have a feeling they're going to come back strong.
Okay.
I know.
Why am I think I am?
I Dunno.
I like losing the weight and that type of shit.
But,
uh,
I,
I think I'm going to be,
I want,
I would like to be more of a,
someone who two picks his battles when I drink.
You know,
like I got to tell you,
Austin is a hard place not to be drinking.
Like,
um,
we uh,
we went to go see Jimmy Vaughan,
like we was sitting at this table with some other people that knew Jimmy and
they,
they were the nicest people ever.
And um,
a couple of them that were at the table,
we'll fucking just doing shots and I swear to God they did like three shots in
an hour and these people could drink because they were just totally like fine.
And um,
I would be lying to you if I looking at them drinking,
going,
God damn it,
I would kill for one of those right now.
Okay.
I was trying to rationalize it.
Like what if I just did one,
and this is the weird thing about me.
If I am,
I'm a habit guy,
so I don't know,
like a chemical person.
I don't think so.
But if I just do that one,
how I work is I immediately have to order a water after that and let the buzz
start to fade.
All right.
Cause if I don't,
then I'm going to get another,
then I'm going to going to get another.
But I,
I got this weird thing with the water.
It,
it fucking,
it's almost like I threw it at my face and I wake up going like,
all right dude,
settle down,
settle down.
But if I don't do that,
um,
I definitely put a dent in a bottle.
But uh,
I dunno,
last night man at that prime a show,
I'm not blaming Primus here when I fucking go off the wagon,
but I was just like,
you know,
what
am I going to try mushrooms?
The fuck is who tries mushrooms for the first time.
It's 49 just had a kid.
I can't have that on my resume.
Right.
Plus I also think the first time you do them,
you should probably be in your house where you feel safe.
But I can't do that now cause I'm a dad and I don't think it would be smart to
do it at a concert while I watched it,
the fucking elephant doing somersaults on a trampoline.
I Dunno.
I'm just throwing this shit out here.
If anybody has any suggestions how to walk that line.
MMM.
Anyways,
now that I've talked about recreational drugs here,
now those recreational,
I don't even know what I didn't know.
I just always say that word on the fucking news.
MMM.
Let me promote the all things comedy festival.
This is the podcast read.
Okay.
We're having our first all things comedy festival at the end of this month.
October 26 27,
28 29.
I'm sorry.
So that goes right through Sunday in Phoenix,
Arizona.
All right.
(262) 072-0820 nine.
So that's Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
I'm going to be there recording my first ever live Monday morning podcast.
All right,
Doug.
Stan hope the Great Doug.
Stan hope the legend is doing his podcast at the Orpheum theater.
Bert Kreischer Silverberg,
Ari Shaffir.
I think he also might be sober.
Uh,
the crab feasts are also on the lineup where taking over downtown Phoenix with a
pop up podcast studio and the whole network is going to be there.
If you're in the Phoenix area,
come hang with us.
Go to the all things,
go to the all things,
comedy.com to get your tickets.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know what time I'm coming in cause I'm coming in from Atlanta.
Actually I'm going out to la to see my wife and kid and then I'm going to fly in
the day of and um,
I'm going to be walking around fucking taking pictures and thanking everybody
for coming out.
So you guys bought tickets to came on.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Um,
all right,
let's get to some of the,
one of the podcast reets here.
Oh look who's here at everybody.
It's one of our favorite fucking reads on the podcast.
It's old zip.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Ziprecruiter is different.
With Zip
[inaudible] dot com you can post your job to over 100 job sites,
swipe over 100 of the web's leading job boards.
Sorry with one click.
Uh,
so you can just rest easy knowing your job is going to be seen by the right
candidates.
Then zip
puts its smart matching technology to work actively notifying qualified
candidates about your job within minutes of posting so you can receive the best
pause possible matches.
Got To get classes.
You can even get a head start on the interview process by adding screening
questions to your job post what to your job posts to help identify the most
qualified candidates ever read a sentence and you don't even,
what the fuck you talking about?
That was one of them.
So you don't have to waste time sorting through the stack of resumes to find the
perfect fit and the easy to use zip.
Um,
dashboard lets you manage your hiring process from start to finish all in one
place.
Find out today.
Why is it
has been used by growing businesses of all sizes and industries to find the most
qualified job candidates with immediate results?
Right now,
my listeners can post jobs on zip.
Okay,
three D
for free.
That's ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] one more time.
Hey,
sip,
recruiter.com/ [inaudible] all right.
Simply say,
getting traditional home security can be a punishing,
an expensive task.
Simply safe home security is a better way to protect your home.
Simply safe.
Got Rid of everything that makes home security a hassle,
man.
They make it easy for you.
The system is easy to use and completely wireless.
You can install it yourself.
Oh,
that's great.
You can do it yourself in under an hour.
Simply safe has no longterm contract.
There's no obligations.
Hey honey,
we had a great night.
Leave it alone.
I don't want a relationship.
This is an award winning home security technology.
Tech magazine seen it calls simply safe,
better,
smarter,
home security.
Your home is protected around the clock with 24,
seven professional monitoring.
If there's trouble,
they'll send police.
Uh,
by the way,
when I send my door was on my wife and kid weren't home.
Okay.
By the way,
just to let you know,
in case you would concern,
uh,
this service cost is $15 a month with simply safe.
That's three times less than what the other guy's charged and simply safe has no
hidden fees.
Protect your home today.
You can buy simply safe at your local best buy and have your home protected by
tonight or simply safe,
[inaudible] dot com for a special 10% off that.
Simply safe bird.com for 10% off your home security systems.
Simply safer.com B,
u r.
R.
A.
Tomorrow,
everybody hang in their movement watches everybody.
Movement watches pronounced movement.
M.
V.
T.
Uh,
it's how they spell it was founded on the belief that style shouldn't break the
bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality minimalist products at revolutionary prices.
The company started by two broke college kids that wanted to where stylists
watches but couldn't afford them.
Okay?
I never understood this.
They're broke and they started a watch company.
How do you do that?
So they started their own watch company.
All right.
How was dislike your,
how you started?
Well,
I was,
uh,
I wasn't broke.
I was living at home with my parents and I worked in a dental office.
I paid off my fucking truck and when it died,
I put a new engine in it rather than buying a new car.
And then I paid off the fucking engine.
And then I finally started making money off of,
uh,
my standup gigs and I started banking that I paid off my student loans.
And then I had an electrical fire in my truck burned down on the side off of
route 24.
And then I said,
well fuck it,
I'm moving to New York anyways.
And uh,
I don't need a car.
So I moved down there and I thought,
well,
I've got to get a day job.
And then got a couple of gigs and then my mindset went from,
you know,
I got to get a day job too.
I got to get more gigs.
Yeah.
I took buses and trains and shit like that.
Okay.
It's sucked in it.
I don't know.
Eventually I started making money 20 years later.
Did you guys really want me to take that big of a left turn during your read?
Cause you could tell me to talk about it.
I will.
Uh,
it's a classic design quality construction style.
Minimalism over 100 million watches sold in 160 countries and it was in Lee,
Massachusetts and somebody threw a fucking dinner roll at me and it missed and
they threw it so hard when it hit the back wall.
That actually scared me.
And this is the thing,
it was a fresh roll too.
He threw it so hard.
It sounded like it sounded like a stale role.
Movement.
Watches start at just $95 one time.
Somebody to dental floss at me when I was on stage,
cause I was talking about working in a dental office at a department store,
you're looking at four to 500 bucks,
uh,
get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to move on.
I used to work for free.
And then I moved out to Oregon for gas money by going to [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] this watch has a really clean design that makes a great
fashion statement.
Now is the time to step up.
Your watch can't go to movement.
watches.com burr joined the movement.
Um,
by the way,
Tim Alexander's fucking drum kit was one of the coolest things I've ever seen.
He has like,
he has like three rack toms and then mixed in with the rack toms on like a rack
above it.
He has like these octa bonds,
like three different octa bonds.
Then he has like these like splash symbols on one side.
He's got like the rack dude.
I'm a drum geek,
so I was videoing the drum kit watching all of this stuff do one of the most
fluid fucking players.
Do you know he was the player that actually got me out of my John Bond initially
got me out of the John Bonham like death spiral and I was like,
I have,
all I'm doing is listening to John Bonam.
This isn't good.
I'm never going to sound like I'm never going to play like him.
I need to listen to other people and the double bass guys,
so many of them,
like what they were playing.
I just couldn't hear a groove.
And then he came along.
And the way he applies the double bass when he puts it in.
And what I love about his playing is how fluid it is in the space that he has,
um,
and just grooves as his ass off.
I can't believe I finally got to sign s psalm to got to see him.
It was just amazing.
Anyways,
stamps.com everybody.
Oh,
the old favorites.
Stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business and can mail.
I can mail any letters,
any packages using just my computer and printer.
And the mailman picks it up.
Avoid the hassle,
man of going to the post office and mail everything from postcards to envelopes
to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes with no equipment to lease and no long
term commitments.
Click print mail chute Chet,
and you're done.
Unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven keyword descriptors.
Convenient,
easy,
reliable,
flexible,
like the horror up the street.
I use stamps.com anytime I send out my posters and when a whore myself out,
signing them afterwards like the poster that will be available.
Okay?
Uh,
this weekend for the first ever live Monday morning podcast.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstampsdotcomenterbirthstamps.com
never go to the post office again.
All right,
where are we here?
Let's get to some of the questions here for this week.
All right.
You're not gonna believe this.
I accidentally hit stop.
So then I had to press record again and somehow I hit stop again without
realizing it and I just talked for 40 fucking minutes.
Then nobody heard.
All right,
let me start this over again with your questions here.
All right.
I'll try to act like I'm still excited that I'm not fucking starving.
Do you hear that?
That's my stomach growling.
Alright,
Robert Plant,
everybody,
all freckles.
Just wanted to let you know.
Robert Plant was interviewed on the Howard Stern show on Tuesday.
He goes through his whole career and up to the present because he has a new
album coming out.
Incredible interview.
Thought you might enjoy it.
Thank you.
And Go fuck yourself.
Ah,
I apps.
I have to hear this fucking interview.
The problem is,
is I only have Sirius satellite radio in my car.
My car's in Los Angeles.
I'm in Atlanta.
Um,
Howard stern fans,
please send me a link.
Let me know where I can see it.
Watch it.
Whatever the fuck it goes on.
However you kids do it because I'm not going to be able to figure it out.
I have to listen to it.
I have to listen to them.
Go through the whole thing and joy and disaplain.
John Bonham dying,
coming back within the mood and then what else?
They do a honey drippers the whole fucking thing.
I can't wait to Plusnet.
You know,
when I was at the Austin City live,
they had an incredible picture of him too.
Um,
you know,
he's another guy,
just age naturally.
Now look at him.
He looks fucking bad ass.
All the wrinkles on his face,
his face,
he just looks at it.
Looks fucking amazing.
Um,
I don't know why people would choose botox and all of that shit.
oh,
here's a great one.
38 year old bus driver makes college hoops team,
uh,
Billy girl.
Did you see these,
uh,
this article on Barstool?
Sounds like someone,
uh,
you would commend on a job well done.
You're always telling people it's never too late.
On the flip side,
what are the negatives here?
Does anyone lose out?
Um,
hey man,
if you can't beat out a six foot,
eight,
380 pound,
fucking 38 year old guy,
it's on Barstool sports,
which by the way is,
you know,
that that's gotta be the best combination of being hilarious.
And then also let you know what's going on in sports.
Um,
how,
let's see,
this guy,
38 years old,
it's going to be 39 in November.
Okay?
He's six feet eight and weighed 380 pounds.
He's 38 waist three 80 you know,
it's funny to get through 380 pounds.
All you have to do is just gain at 38 years of age.
All you have to do is just gain 10 pounds a year.
You know,
for the first,
like I don't know how many years,
people are like,
oh my God,
the kids are May,
she ate it then all of a sudden,
right?
Yeah.
Nine years old,
you're 90 pounds.
Like what the fuck?
Okay.
10 year,
120 a 200 and next,
you know,
three 80.
He just kept getting better.
Like giant hasn't,
but you just keep eating.
Um,
you're asking me what is the downsize,
the downside.
Sorry,
downsize.
We'll slip there.
What is the downside?
Maybe is a blown out his achilles.
I,
man,
I'll feel bad if somebody can't beat out of fucking soon to be 39 year old,
380 pounds,
six foot eight guy.
You know what that division,
whatever division that is,
that's amazing.
Good for him,
man.
Good Fam.
You know what it is?
He said his basketball dream died and he's 38 years old,
going to be 39.
It has two teenage kids.
It's like there's,
we get dream died.
You fucking had the kids man and you're a good dad.
I bet you.
So you're just like,
oh,
I got to take whatever job I can get.
Um,
all right.
The fall guy,
no,
sorry.
Brain activity after death.
Oh my God,
I can't believe I already did this.
I talked
I this,
I hope I can do this justice again.
Brain activity at after death.
All right,
let's,
let's reminisce about this one because I've already read it before.
All right.
When I first recorded this but didn't realize I wasn't recording,
let me check again to make sure this fucking thing is on.
Um,
that freaked me out.
Brain activity after death and I was just like,
cause in my will,
I'm going to get cremated.
So I'm like,
you know,
even still,
if you have brain activity you have to death.
I'd rather just get thrown in an oven to just finish off the rest of me.
Like,
ah,
it's over real quick.
As opposed to laying in a coffin,
feeling worm's going into my ears.
Um,
dear Billy ripper.
This article absolutely fucked me up.
Not only his death going to suck,
but also I feel the need to know I filled the need down to make sure people
don't talk shit about me as I'm dying or here let's get a pizza has,
I'm about ready to checkout for good.
All right.
This freaked me out here.
MMM.
All right.
Scientists say your brain still works after death and you know when you're dead.
Now.
I saw a thing a long time ago.
Yeah.
Where this scientist was on TV with this religious guy who was talking about
people who died and then came back to life and then they talked about what they
saw and what they heard and all that.
And it was all this fascinating stuff about watching people working on them and
floating above the table and all of this type of shit.
And then the scientist guy just killed all of it by going like,
uh,
nothing has ever been dead and has been brought back to life.
What you're talking about here is people having a near death experience.
Just because your heart stops,
it doesn't mean you're dead.
Your brain is still working.
You can still,
and he basically was saying your,
if your eyes are open,
you know you can still see some shit.
We're not sure how much you still alive.
It's not until your brain has no function.
That's the final,
the final part of it.
I remember reading when I read that book,
a perfect storm.
They went through all of drowning.
Yeah,
and how your brains sitting there firing all that,
that last bit of life,
all this brain activities go and try and get your heart going and it just
doesn't happen.
And then that's it from the lack of oxygen.
Then your brain dies last and then that's it.
But you don't like fucking live,
I mean not dead.
You're not dead yet.
Right.
Anyways,
scientists may be inching closer to answering one of the greatest mysteries of
life.
What happens after you die according what is over?
You're doing?
Don't you hate those fucking websites where you skip past the advertising and
you scroll down and then they show a t anyways,
fucking annoying.
Um,
according to researchers in New York,
a person's brain is still active after death,
meaning in many cases they can be aware that they've passed away.
A team from New York University,
Lang Gone,
school of medicine has been studying patients who suffered cardiac arrest or a
heart attack,
which stops their heart for a period of time.
Quote,
technically speaking,
that's how you get the time of death.
It's all based on the moment when the heart stops.
Yeah,
but you're not dead.
You're not dead.
Your heart just stopped.
That's why they can bring it back to life cause you still alive.
They just get the fucking thing going again.
I learned all of this from one scientist.
They'll describe watching doctors and nurses working.
They'll describe having awareness of full conversations of visible with the
yeah,
but should your ears didn't die.
If you scream in an air,
it's still going to fucking vibrate cause it's still alive.
It's still working.
The heart stopped.
Um,
anyways,
they knew all this shit that they otherwise wouldn't have known what was going
on.
Um,
according to Parnia,
these recollections was then verify by the medical staff.
Yeah.
This is all stupid.
Your cause you're not dead yet,
sir.
You're not dead.
All right,
so just fucking let go of that.
I think you know what I think happens when you die.
I think it's a beautiful experience.
I think it's what my idea of what fucking mushrooms and a primus concert is
like.
I think he's laying there.
I think you're totally relaxed.
You let go all of the bullshit
and heal.
If you're lucky enough after your heart stopped to kind of be aware of a little,
to be aware that you're dying.
I think it would be very humble experience and I would give thanks for the
amazing life that I had and if there was nothing after it,
I would,
I would be good.
But I would be fine with going into the ground and enriching the soil with my
carcass.
I don't need to go anywhere.
After this.
I went to fucking,
I performed at Austin City live.
I then saw Jimmy Vaughn.
I then went to an f one race and then saw Primus,
I need to go to Heaven after that.
Fuck.
Are you talking about?
Um,
yeah.
I don't think it's this big fearful thing.
I don't think it is.
I think it's somebody tortures you to death.
The torture is bad.
That's the bad thing.
How you die.
He's bad.
But I don't think the death that being dead is bad.
I think,
I think it would be fucking amazing.
I think it's going to be amazing.
Why would you think anything else?
You can't stop.
It might as well look at it in a positive way.
I remember when,
um,
who's that guy?
Uh,
Lou?
Jesus Christ.
His only a legend.
It was in that band that sang about fucking heroin.
Lou Reed.
I remember they said when he died,
this woman said she was looking at me and he had the most like amazed and like
inquisitive look on his face.
Like he was totally enjoying it and just taking in the fucking experience.
That's how you want to go out.
You don't go,
oh,
Hey God,
I'm sorry I'm doing all that shit.
Fuck that.
Don't fight it.
Just give it to it.
What do you special?
Are you going to keep fucking living like a vampire?
Uh,
the fall guy?
dear bill,
big red balls of fire.
Um,
I don't have a question.
More of an observation on Harvey Weinstein,
the Harvey Weinstein situation.
Harvey Weinstein is banned from the Oscars little elite club.
It's not a little club.
It's a fucking,
it is a very elite club.
And I could tell by,
uh,
I already said this shit before I knew that this guy has issues with Hollywood.
I believe,
you know my saying little elite club,
uh,
the same club that Roman Polanski,
a pedophile who pled guilty.
He did not plead guilty to being a pedophile.
He,
what he pled guilty to was improper behavior.
That's what he was willing to plead guilty to.
And then he ran and got the fuck out of the country because that's what innocent
people do.
Although if I was brought up on those charges in another country,
I probably would have got the fuck out of there too.
However,
I would never be in a hot tub with a fucking 13 year old girl giving her booze
or whatever the fuck was going on.
Um,
and Bryan singer who's been accused of molesting underage child stars and
feeding them drugs are a part of,
uh,
the big Hollywood elite club that the sick bastards want us to believe is
honorable.
Um,
I dunno if anybody ever said it was honorable.
Uh,
you sat on your previous podcast that this was one of the mo I guess say they
try,
this is for film and honoree.
I,
maybe they do.
I don't pay attention to the shit.
I watch sports.
Uh,
you start on your previous podcasts that,
that this was one of the most disgusting God awful situation.
Do you ever heard of the Weinstein thing?
Yeah.
Weinstein fucked up.
Sure.
Cool.
But so far none of his accusers were underage.
I swear to God.
I know what you guys are thinking.
You're thinking what?
I thought the first time I read this,
this guy is not going to downplay what Weinstein did a,
you know,
he fucked up.
They allegedly did.
I guess I should still be saying alleging what'd he allegedly Dan,
the guy fucked up.
A lot of them were aspiring stars who were willing to do anything for fame.
Objection,
speculation.
Dude.
You're just creating this fucking argument because you have issues with
Hollywood and their careers failed and now they're bitter.
So they,
yeah.
Okay.
All right.
This,
you sound like the defense attorney for a Harvey Weinstein right now,
but no one,
all in capital capital's mentions to pedophile pedophilia cases involving other
tensile moguls,
uh,
cause it would completely ruin the industry.
That's not true.
It's been mentioned.
People have said stuff like that.
They don't have evidence to bring charges.
Okay.
This is what happens to,
same reason why,
how are we YC probably won't go to jail like the level of fucking evidence that
you need in order to bring charges.
Okay.
It's a difficult fucking thing when you're dealing with people with that level
of power,
trying to catch them in the act.
You know,
how long did they know that these mafia dons are doing what they're doing?
How often did they know that these fucking oil companies and insurance companies
and all of these people are Catholic Church and all these people?
Do they have money?
They got money,
dude.
Okay,
so I don't know why you're just singling out Hollywood.
What are your Fox News,
you know,
or CNN when they just single out fucking Trump for grabbing pussies.
Um,
I don't understand you can you forget if you're going to fucking lay waste,
you got to go straight across the board here.
Um,
anyways,
it's made this,
uh,
but okay,
watch this documentary.
If you could find it called an open secret.
All right,
well meaning what?
That I'm out in Hollywood.
I don't know that this shit's going on.
I guess it means it's an open secret with the people that know those people.
This is a classic fucking guy who watches a God damn documentary.
He's not a fucking lawyer.
He doesn't even know how to present his fucking argument.
It's all speculation
that are willing to do anything for fame.
Like where did you get that?
You just pulled that out of the year.
You're asked to support your fucking argument here.
I'm not saying this shit isn't going on,
but like a,
you know,
there's all kinds of people that fly over to these third world countries
evidentaly and are doing,
God knows what with under aged shit,
uh,
kids.
So I don't know why you just singling this out.
I mean,
if you're going to attack this,
shouldn't you be against it straight across the fucking board?
Or maybe you're just saying this because the Weinstein thing came about.
I don't know what you're doing.
It's the fact that you're downplaying what Harvey Weinstein allegedly did.
That's what's weird in me out here.
Anyways,
that documentary and open secret,
it's made by the same director who made deliver us from evil,
which is about the pedophilia in the Catholic church.
Well,
this director is either fighting the good fight or picking low hanging fruit
here.
That movie was released in theaters and got the,
for the most part,
major distribution from film companies.
But an open secret hasn't had a wide release in it's two years.
That is premiered.
Yeah.
Why do you think,
why do you think,
why don't you make a fucking documentary about how fucked the oil oil industry
is and try to get the oil industry to put it out.
They're not going to,
they're not going to shoot themselves in the foot because at the end of the day,
money wins.
All right.
Same Way.
Why the NFL acted like they didn't see that ray rice fucking thing.
Um,
it's still unknown by a majority of the populous.
Weinstein is taking the shitstorm while the real monsters is saying,
phew,
good thing we're not in the forefront.
It's bullshit.
A,
okay.
I can't understand if you're saying Weinstein shouldn't be,
he should be taking a shitstorm,
but not the whole shit storm.
I think that's what you're trying to say here.
Corey Feldman and Elijah Wood mentioned pedophilia is running rampant in
Hollywood,
but no one gives that issue the time of day.
Um,
I would actually argue that they're trying to investigate it,
but people have such high levels of power because what I've learned from the
Harvey Weinstein thing,
when I listened to that disgusting tape of him saying,
I'm used to this,
knowing that that tape wasn't enough to arrest him is,
uh,
I mean,
you're borderline have to catch somebody in the act
when they have that level of money because then it becomes your word against
their word and then they have money to tie it up forever in court.
It's terrible.
Anyways,
RV is,
is equivalent to a nerd who's dep desperate to get laid.
All right,
dude,
I'm done with this fucking thing.
I'm done with this thing.
You know what's funny cert in all of this,
you're going after these,
so you feel that pedophiles should be punished.
I agree.
But you feel that creeps like Harvey Weinstein or just are the equivalent to a
nerd who's desperate to get laid.
Okay.
That's how you view alleged rape.
I mean,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I Dunno where you're going with that,
sir.
But,
uh,
you know,
you wrote a lot of words.
All right.
MILF question.
Hey Bill,
you fucking cunt.
Um,
all right.
Guilty as charged.
You know what?
The guy who wrote that,
Harvey Weinstein,
I think we were sitting down.
Sometimes people writing isn't there the best way for them to communicate.
Maybe if we sat down and we actually talked,
I can understand what the fuck he was saying.
All right.
MILF question.
Hey Bill,
you fucking cunt.
I love your podcast and all your standups.
F is for family is fucking great too.
Thank you.
Anyways,
I need some advice on 24 and I work at a bar as a sound guy until I graduate,
which is this December.
Anyways,
last week,
a beautiful redheaded woman who's about 40 starts to hit on me.
I gave her my number and lately I've been texting her banging a MILF has been
always been on my bucket list.
I just,
that's just fucking gross to me.
I don't know why.
I just think that's fucking gross.
Why you have
to bring up the fact that she's a mother and has a kid and you want to fucker is
just weird.
Why can't you just say she's hot?
However,
this woman is starting to seem like she wants more than just a night or two of
fucking,
she has a kid,
which I don't fucking want to deal with whatsoever.
So here's my question.
How do I deal with this?
You fucking why walk away,
walk away.
And I understand that you're not understanding these red flags because you're 24
years old and your deck is just running the situation.
I'll read the rest as he goes.
I mean,
I want to hook up with her,
but I don't really want a relationship with the 40 year old broad with the kid.
We haven't done anything yet.
Great.
Great time to ask for help.
He said,
but we're going on a date this Friday as always fuck your own face and go
Bruins.
Um,
yeah dude.
MMM.
I would walk away.
I wouldn't even go out with her.
I would just walk the fuck away.
MMM.
Because they'll tell you right now,
you know she wants a relationship.
All right?
So right now if you're just going to fuck her and then leave,
that's kind of bad.
Be Bad.
Karma.
Not that I really believe in.
Well,
I kind of do,
but I thought,
I don't know.
I've,
I actually believe you have to believe in Karma for it to come back and get you.
Um,
because in reality,
bad shit's going to happen anyways.
Then you'd be like home.
That's my Karma.
MMM.
I would,
uh,
yeah,
I need a break that date off or I would tell her beforehand,
which is going to piss her off and then she's not going to bang anyways.
The time to have had that conversation in the future,
sir.
When you meet an older woman and they know what the fuck they want,
um,
when they hitting on you or whatever,
you just,
just let him know you're single and you just trying to have fun.
You're not trying to get into a relationship and you just throw that out there
and if they still jump on the fucking hook parliament and the boat,
if not,
you got to catch and release,
catch and release.
All right.
Is that it?
Is that the podcast for this week?
God Damn it that I do enough frigging time.
MMM.
All right.
I have a lot of people to thank this week.
I want to thank all you guys for listening.
I want to thank everybody who's going to be coming out to the podcast festival
in Phoenix.
I want to thank Primus for putting on a fucking amazing show.
Uh,
we got to go backstage,
me and dean and meet him for a second.
They were the nicest,
coolest fucking people ever.
Everybody around him,
everybody was awesome.
MMM.
Jimmy Vaughan,
another great guy,
another amazing show.
Thank you for the amazing show.
Thank you to him and his wife for being so cool and being such great.
Yeah,
just great people.
Uh,
everybody at one.
I just,
I just had a fucking great time.
Got To give shout and thank you to well Buxton for throwing in the Rikki rocket
for the Danny Ricardo intro.
Uh,
and that's it.
Um,
I'll check in on you guys on Thursday.
What about the fucking rams?
The Los Angeles Rams?
What would happen if they actually sold out that giant fucking stadium for a
regular season game?
Come on Los Angeles.
They're from there.
They left once you got your old girlfriend back treat or right trader.
Right.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you
on a Thursday.